nature and nature genetics bring
together reports from three teams using
new techniques for studying whole
genomes of thousands of individuals to
discover where addiction to nicotine and
the link between smoking and cancer may
lie the teams who found the genetic
markers were based in the USA Europe and
Iceland
the fascinating thing here is that the
three papers the two in nature one in
nature genetics have all found robust
associations of the same chromosomal
loci or area of the chromosome with lung
cancer but they've reached rather
different conclusions on whether or not
that is mediated through a propensity to
smoke more cigarettes or be addicted to
nicotine so two of the papers suggest
that the association's really with lung
cancer not with smoking the other paper
suggests that the association is really
with smoking and that's the reason that
lung cancer risk has increased in
Iceland Kari Stefansson found a
correlation between a particular gene
locus and the tendency to become
addicted to nicotine the dependence of
nicotine of the use of nicotine through
smoking is one of the big health hazards
in our society you inherit the tendency
to become addicted to nicotine you
inherit a tendency to seek the
environment which is a tobacco smoke
that clearly contributes to the
development of lung cancer in Iceland
thousands of people have had their whole
genetic code analyzed this has recently
produced new and exciting data about
human disease when you have a large
group of people in a small nation like
the Icelandic nation having the
genealogy gives us an opportunity to
impute the genome but about three times
more people than we have actually put
work into studying and then we have the
genealogy and actually the genealogy of
the entire nation going thousand years
back in time using samples from
different populations the other two
groups identified a different reason for
the correlation with disease
but all three groups found the same
marker the excitement is through
genome-wide Association studies were
able to locate a place in the genome
that now serves as the beginning of a
very exciting set of discovery and
investigative activities that will
hopefully give us that opportunity to
give plausibility and biological
understanding to why that part of the
genome is so important for risk for
developing smoking problems or lung
cancer we look here we see all of the
different chromosomes are represented by
different colors with their markers here
and you can see in chromosome 15 that
these signals that are above the blue
line they're suggesting that there are
very strong statistical signals you then
you say what part of the genome is this
looking we pointed on chromosome 15 and
we say that part of the genome has a set
of very interesting genes there's an
awful lot of similarity particularly in
the region where there's signal seen in
some of these studies we really have to
look specifically at what's going on
genetically so now this is the
excitement we see aha
this particular asset eel choline
receptor 5 alpha wow that's a great gene
people have been interested in that for
nicotine addiction for quite some time
and there's been some very exciting
reports all we know right now is that
smoking and lung cancer are showing up
in this particular region here and since
we know smoking a lung cancer so closely
related to each other and in the studies
that are reported almost all the lung
cancer patients had been smokers we
can't ferret that out yet
thousands of people studied and in each
individual millions of gene fragments
the new techniques help find locations
in the genome that are very important to
us all
we inherit from our Father and our
mother one copy of each particular gene
variant each of these gene variants
basically breaks down into three
clusters when we actually do the
analysis there's always a contribution
both by the environment and by the
genetics to the risk or that particular
phenotype of that particular disease
malade father was an avid smoker right
he smoked pipe as a young man and when
the big propaganda against a cigarette
smoking began he said I'm not going to
let these people tell me how to behave
and his who evade the pipe and started
to smoke cigarettes and he died from
lung cancer at the age of 67
unfortunately I tried to smoke as a
teenager I failed completely I am one of
these miserable failures as a smoker and
and I just became nauseated and threw up
but then I have a daughter who was an
avid smoker and and she smokes even all
two cigarettes a little bit like of late
grandfather so put these findings lead
to tests which could help us decide what
our risks are and how to behave as
individuals carry steffensen's lab
offers similar tests already
I'm very optimistic with in due course
we will be able to use samples and use
this genetic information to be part of a
paradigm for assessing personal and
public health risk this will occur I
think over the coming years but it's
certainly not quite ready yet what
people ask whether they should go and
get tested for these and other variants
and I think right now we're not ready to
recommend testing for such a large
number of gene variants across so many
conditions where the data is still in
evolution we're going to find out more
the biggest problem is this is a deluge
of information and we've got no
experience in communicating that
information to individuals if people
wish to go and get tested there are some
companies setting up to do it and that's
people's own shorts but I don't think
we're ready to recommend that as a
clinical activity at this point what is
important to keep in mind here is that
it should be the decision of the
individual whether or not they want to
learn about risk and people should at
least be given an opportunity or
learning the risk and then deciding on
their own whether or not it is enough
for them to change the behavior and I
resent the patronizing view that people
are not ready to learn about it risk a
very substantial part of who we are is
the risk that we have of the common
diseases that kill more people so I
think that we are always ready to learn
more about ourselves early days or not
David hunter thinks all three papers
signal important ways forward it's a
wonderful time because we really finally
can access the iceberg underneath the
tip that we knew was there when we talk
about inherited predisposition disease
the discovery element is really the key
part of genome-wide associations at this
point in developing druggable targets
based on what we see in these regions is
really another one of the
next-generation sets of studies that
have to go forward smoking has so many
different ill effects that it's very
very unlikely that will be anybody to
whom we could responsibly say you know
it's safe to smoke so the population
wide advice is likely to remain
I'm challenged whatever way this comes
out smoking is still a very bad thing to
be doing
you